hello everyone and welcome back to the
final match of the 2020 chasuble masters
between Hikaru Nakamura and the ding
leader and first ding won the first
match nahi kar retaliated in the second
one and this is now the third one
whoever wins this faces Magnus Carlsen
in the semifinals of the chasuble
Masters and the first game of the third
match ended in a draw then this is the
second game and this is the one that
we're showing he car with the white
pieces they go into the the line of the
Berlin that they already played but here
with a bit of a twist so let's check it
out he Carl with the white pieces opens
with efore sorry about that
and I would just like to make a short
announcement if you guys are interested
in some other games other than other
than chess I will be streaming some
other games like some old classics or
maybe some some newer ones on my twitch
channel so do check it out if you're
interested I will put a link to my
twitch channel in the description below
but if you're just interested in chess
most of the big chess streams that I
will stream will be will still be on
YouTube of course so that being said
adding replies with E 5 we have night of
three nights the c6 and Bishop to b5 the
reuleaux pieces on the board as we
mentioned it's going to be a nice Berlin
so night of six and B 3 so the same line
they already played Bishop c5 characters
characters and now just castles we have
Knight to d7 defending the e5 pawn we
already mentioned this many times night
is coming to c4 to add another attacker
to e5 so black castles Knight to c4 and
rook to e8 now defending the e5 pawn we
have a four and now adding just prevents
any further expansion by going a five
and here King to H 1 and B 3 are no
moves but now Bishop to e3 Hikaru offers
the trade of dark square Bishop and it
would be very good if this Knight came
over here you have access to the f5
square and if black wants the prevented
you either have to weaken your King side
further or you will have to give up your
bishop for the night
so instead a dingos Bishop to b4 and
this is a really interesting move it's a
really interesting move because it kind
of baits
c3 and it's very interesting what
happens here so here first Knight f2 d2
open
to bring this night over to see for
after this Night Moves but also freeing
up the f4 point if needed so f6 now just
strengthening the pawn and c3 now
kicking the bishop back but also adding
support for future d4 so better back to
f8 and now Queen to c2 so just
continuing development we have b6
binding and now d4 we eat captures on d4
n now see cap for Sunday for and now
what's very interesting and this is
probably my favorite move of the game
you know how you when you're playing a
game you have to you know how do I
develop my pieces of which piece
position can I improve can i optimize
something which piece of mine is doing
nothing which is which piece of mind is
really terrible can I improve it and
here you might think of a lot of moves
but the moved in place I really liked he
plays a nice back to b8 and it seems
weird like you don't have any of the
pieces pretty much developed and you
bring your knight back but the hardest
move to find or often is I move with the
knight back and here you are planning
nights the a6 the b4 and with the sea
and upon being gone you do not have any
points to kick away this knife from B 4
and B 4 will be an excellent outpost for
the night so that's why Knights the b8
and okay there's nothing wife can do to
prevent this so Hikaru continues
developing rook a to C 1 we have knife
to a6 and rook F to D 1 now we have
Knights the before and now Queen to B 1
as the Queen is under attack and now
Bishop to e6 so just continuing
development preparing to bring the Queen
over to put more pressure here on the
night end on the B 3 square so b3
defending and now Queen to d7 with the
plan we already mentioned f3 key card
strength in the center and now Queen to
f7 and here but should be back to f2 we
look eat a d8 now putting the rook on
the D file and now you might have some
problems with b5 comes then characters
captures the knight has the move might
be a lot of pressure on the c3 point so
here hikaru does a rook lift rook the c3
I had to help out with the defense of
the 3rd rank but b5 nonetheless so the
knight is under attack we have Knight
back to be to now the night and
both the guarding the pawn here ended
the night covers the a Foursquare if B
character Sunday for happens so here we
have rook a to be eight biding he wants
the capped run a for and have his rook
on the same file as he Carlos Queen so
he karo characters instead we have eight
captors and be five and now Nazi captors
but rather rook actress adding still
wants to have his rook over on the B
file we have night beat the C for now
and here comes a four so that's why the
rook wanted the character on b5 and the
point is if you go be character Sunday
for the problem is this Knight to d5 is
just very strong for for black now you
have problems you your rook your queen
is under attack your rope is under
attack and if you go for captures then
just captures and you will lose the
other rook as well and after that you
will also lose the knight and C 4 and so
on so after a four we have rug D to see
one now such ideas are no longer a
problem because this rook is nicely
defended and here we have looked back to
a eight my dink beak a person a for
sorry Rudy to c1 and now rook to a eight
and now preparing a three to create a
passed pawn here so be characters on a
four now attacking the pawn and now
Knight to d5 doesn't do anything because
if Knight to d5 now you can simply
capture the rook and there is no problem
after Knight captures you will simply
recapture the night and this is defended
twice all these well white is up a piece
and of course winning so after big
characters on a for now we have rook
captures on a four and here we have rook
to a3 so not an easy position for white
and it's hard to find a move a lot of
nasty discoveries are lurking everywhere
and here he Cara played rook to a3
now he wants the to make this trade
happened here and he also wants to get
his Knight away from c4 however this
doesn't this doesn't work so feel free
to pause the video and try to find the
absolute best best move for doing while
I give you a couple of seconds so for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations on being an excellent
discoverer of
discoveries and for those of you who
just wanna enjoy the show it's night to
a two and now the point is your queen is
under attack and your rook is under
attack and you cannot defend both and
the problem with Queen captures night
here is that now you can play rook
captures on a three and the knight
cannot recapture because it's been so
that's dings plan so P Carl says I'm not
I'm not giving you the exchanger that's
like resigning I mean I don't have any
compensation here so I have to rook to
a3 and nights the a2
hikaru actually played rook captures an
a4 he sacrificed the Queen and okay
ding said rook capture Sun be one we
have rook captures some be one in now at
night the c3 not only that but the ding
will also now pick up one of the rooks
so rook betta a one and now Knight
characters on a forum we have rook
actress on a four in here Queen to d8
and now Hikaru has a knight and the rook
for a queen which is not terrible and he
does have a better pawn structure he is
well he doesn't have much but it is
still playable so rook the a6 he goes
for the pawn here and now Queen to c8
another brilliant well tactic tactic
slash trap from ding attacking the rook
pushing the rogue back and asking what
do you want to do here and here he karo
should definitely go back however he
went for rook captures in c6 and now
once again feel free to pause the video
and try to find the winning move for
ding here while I give you a couple of
seconds so for those who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting that the
rook has no escape squares and for those
who just want to enjoy the show its
Bishop to d7 and now the rook really
doesn't have any escape squares this is
covered by the dark square bishop light
square bishop pawn queen and you don't
have anything here see if I've also
covered by the bishop so yeah the
Nakamura play nights the b6 here of
course you cannot capture because rook
rook would capture Queen but it still
doesn't help Queen b7 and now the rook
is under attack so you can move the rook
and lose a piece or you can give up yet
another exchange so here a knight
capture Sun d7 Queen captures and c6 and
now Knight captures on f8 we have Queen
to see one with check first night 2f
and now comes King characters on f8 and
now it's a queen against the bishop at
night however it's not all that all that
simple because well here we have g4 by
Nakamura g6 and now King to g2 we have
f5 Bing wants to open up the position to
make use of the Queen so G captures on
f5 we have G captures in night
the g3 now going after the pawn now
asking do you want to push or do you
want to trade and here ding just trades
caught very confidently we have
characters captures and now being
started bringing the King into King
inter game King f7 and now h4 we have h6
and night to g3 and now if you look at
the position it's not easy to spot how
black can win this because you cannot
push this point you cannot push this
pawn the pawn and Bishop covered the c5
square so that point is not going
anywhere so how do you make progress
here with only the Queen and the king
well dingos kinked at e 6 we have Knight
to e4 and the King to d5 now we have
knight back to g3 he core is very happy
just to repeating moves saying you come
up with a plan
King c4 biding and here Hikaru goes h5
he says ok my pawn will not be nicely
defended on h5 we have Queen to g5 now
pinning the night also the knight cannot
move or or you lose the pawn we have
Bishop to g1 just repeating moves and
now King back to d5 so ding decided to
do something else now we have Bishop to
f2 King e6 better back to g1 and the
Queen to d2 with check with Bishop back
to f2 and now Queen to d3 and now it's
very interesting how do you break
through here the Nakamura tried a very
active plan he doesn't want to try and
keep the king away from the pawns but
it's very interesting what happens if
let's say Bishop to g1 what happens if
you just repeats Bishop g1 Bishop f2 how
do you win you win by going king of 6
and then after let's say white repeats
then you get finally to g5 and once you
land on f4 that's just winning for
example the strip g1 King f4 and now the
f3 pawn falls and there's not much you
can do about this so he car instead went
for a different plan and active one
night f2 he allows the king to go for
the f5 Square widget Inge
we have King to f5 in now tonight III
check King g5 now the king will be able
to gobble up the h5 pawn and now Knight
to g4 now he wants to play Bishop III
and then pick up the pawn on h6 so if
you eliminated this pawn then it's well
then it's much much closer to a sort of
a fortress and for whites to actually
get a draw here so King characters on h5
and the Bishop to e3 but now another
excellent move from dink queen c3 saying
okay if you capture with the night I
just capture your Bishop and if you
capture with the bishop I'm gonna
capture your pawn here and then the past
C pawn just wins
so King f2 guarding the bishop now
preparing to bring a capture with the
night but now King h4 and now there is a
problem here you still cannot capture on
h6 if you capture with the night then
comes Queen c2 you check King f1 and
King g3 and there's not much you can do
here checkmate is near you can go Knight
a5 check in capture sign f3 but now
you're getting checkmated there's no way
no way to avoid this and also well the
night is just under attack it's it's
pointless to continue this so here
what hikaru played is Bishop captures
and h6 if you don't do this if you just
allow the passport to be put forward
this game over so might as well just
capture it so if you captured it but now
being captures the d4 pawn it comes with
check King e2 now King G 3 we have
Bishop to d2 and now comes Queen to c4
check with King III now comes Queen b3
check King to d4 and now c5 check and
now this point is just a winning pass
pawn so King before and here Queen
captures on f3 check was played and it
was in this position almost 63 that he
Cara Nakamura resigned the game and what
a brilliant victory for Dingley reign
and now I will mention the result of the
3rd game as we will not be covering that
one the third game was also won by ding
which means ding wins the third match
ending goes to the semi-finals and
Nakamura is out of the 22 any chasuble
masters so ding will face Magnus Carlsen
in the semi-finals so we're gonna have a
lot of action so
no worries there and yeah it's it was
quite the game really a brilliant tactic
tactical game all around from ding
leerin first winning that exchange and
then he cover didn't want to give up the
exchange he gave up the Queen and it was
a very close to a fortress but not
really as it you know the f fortresses
are like that you it's always very close
to a fortress but it almost never is sir
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
I would like to thank Dixit Varma John
Greenblatt John Gear law office Garry
record and Philip listen for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thankful for watching and I will see you
soon
continuing the coverage of the 22 an
adjustable masters checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day